hello so this week I did something I
don't do nearly as often as I probably
should do I decided to go and give some
blood good morning everybody
this will be the second time ever that I
have given blood in my life
little Emily on my shoulder is coming
along to help me film it and what time's
it don't leave in one minute we have to
leave in one minute okay quick warning
there will be blood in this video but it
is my blood so if it does scare you then
I will take it personally oh I forgot to
mention there are also needles in this
video so if you don't like those still
watch the video just do it with your
eyes closed or something how about that
okay resume first off I had to take know
a bunch of times on a form to confirm
that I was definitely eligible to give
blood while also confirming I probably
haven't had a very adventurous life is
there heard just try to focus once I've
had it in my form I had to read through
some very important documentation which
you should definitely take the time to
read through as thoroughly as you
possibly can do but which I could not
focus on for the life of me because I
was much too worried about how the video
is going I'm not taking any of it in
after that I had to register to confirm
with them exactly who I was and what I
was doing there and to continue to feel
really bad because I still hadn't
finished reading through my documents
and they told me to get hydrated which
is an incredibly important part of
making sure that my body was going to be
able to make mint the fluids that it was
about to lose was that a good one
feeling a little bit nervous I then went
into a booth for a private screening or
not so private for me because you were
there long time by my choice I should
add finally they forced me to take the
time to finish reading all of the
important information that I was
supposed to read earlier then I signed a
contract to fully confirm that I
definitely understood everything and
then it was finally time for me to give
blood a whole drop of my blood and I did
it everyone and I'm I'm very proud of
myself and I bet you're proud of me too
I'll see you next time give blood
everyone good bye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy not really what
they do is they take one drop of your
blood and if it seems to the bottom of
this test tube as mine did that means I
had good iron levels and I was finally
confirmed that I could give blood for
real next it was off to the donation
chair where the nurse picked my right
arm to donate with because apparently
that's where my best vein is don't worry
left arm vein is still very special to
me I promise there's a good vein though
then they gave me some more leaflets
that I could learn the correct exercises
to do while I was donating I've got to
remember to M
hence my bat muscles at last they then
lowered me into the donation position
they gave my armored quick clean and
then before I knew it there was a needle
stuck in my arm and I was given blood I
mean now that it's in I do feel just
kind of fine I can feel sort of like a
dull pain but I mean it's okay
but biscuits and tea to come so I'm just
focusing on that now normally they don't
let you fill the needle so bit of a
charlieissocoollike exclusive right
there
but I've also never actually looked at
the needle while it's been in my arm
before because I've just been kind of
too scared to do it so watching this
footage back was the first time I'd ever
seen what the needle looks like and I've
got to be honest the picture I had the
needle in my head was so much worse than
what it actually looks like it really
was fine I did my exercises as requested
I opened and closed my hand to keep my
blood flowing and it came out to be
pretty quickly so I was only in the
chair for about five minutes apparently
I've got a good vein and I've got a good
flow rate you go good blue I got good
flow they probably tell everyone I got a
good flow right down like just to make
him feel better no just me
I'm all done the machine is beeping what
I did stop flowing they bandaged me all
up gave me some more leaflets and then
set me down at the tea table so I could
eat biscuits until I felt better now if
you're interested in giving blood which
I hope you now are the NHS has actually
been nice enough to help me set up my
own blood drive donation session which
you can come to I will be there not
donating but helping out at the tea
table and it will be at this time and
location I don't know what it is right
now but editing will save me from that
all of the information you need about
how to come and register and all that
I'll put down in the description and if
you can't come to that one I'll put more
information about how to give blood
generally down there as well that is the
given blood video hope to see you at the
thingy good bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool thank you very
much for watching if you'd like to see
him a previous video where I went to New
York City for Fashion Week yes that is a
real thing that actually happens that
videos right there should you want to
watch it and that's all for me thank you
very much for watching again goodbye